(mellow electronic music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're talking about the Enneagram
and we're talking about
specifically my number
and your number.
If you don't know what the
crap we're talking about,
well, we'll give you a
little bit of primer on that
to start out.
- Yeah, I mean, okay.
You know I'm Mr. Disclaimer
so I'm going to give you a few disclaimers
before we get started.
First of all.
- "Rondstadt," don't forget.
- The first disclaimer
is the third episode
of "Ronstadt" is out.
This is where you get to meet
one of Link's characters.
Maybe, I mean, I think
my favorite character
that you play is Gus Twitty.
- Oh, really?
- But this is really, this is.
- Knee Slapper is my favorite.
- It's a very good character as well.
- Yeah, you get to meet Knee Slapper,
episode three on "Ronstadt."
So wherever you get your podcasts.
It's scripted.
You can catch up at any time.
Get on the train.
- Few disclaimers.
The first disclaimer is for anybody
who knows anything about the Enneagram,
you already know that everyone
did their Enneagram podcast
like four years ago, minimum,
and so we're late to the
game and these disclaimers
are actually coming through my wife,
who is the most knowledgeable person
I know about the Enneagram.
So just to let you know,
this is from losfamgeles,
Jessie Lane Interiors.
- Oh gosh, I don't.
But we're not,
that's not the podcast we're doing anyway.
- The bigger disclaimer is
what she wanted me to do.
She said, "Don't tell me
you're doing an episode
on the Enneagram."
She said, "Are you going
to do what everybody does
and you're going to not bring on an expert
to talk about the Enneagram.
You're going to talk out of
your ass about the Enneagram
and you're going to
misinform and miseducate."
I said, "No, no, no, no."
That is not what we're doing
because we are not trying
to educate you about the Enneagram.
We are talking about our
experience with the Enneagram.
But just in case you're the
kind of person who wants
to be oriented to what the Enneagram is
if you're not already
in order to then enjoy
or appreciate the discussion
that we're going to have,
I do encourage you to go to other sources
to figure out what the Enneagram is.
Because we're going to give
a very brief explanation
but this is not comprehensive
and it's not meant to be
authoritative in any way.
Okay?
- Man, you're really hedging.
It's like you almost sound like a one,
like a perfectionist,
who's like if I,
if I'm gonna be criticized for this,
I don't wanna do it.
- A self pres three is the closest
to a one of any spot on the Enneagram.
Now the other thing I'll say along
that lines is there's a
bunch of great sources.
I'm a little bit biased
towards the Enneagram Institute
just because it's a website, not a book.
So it was really easy
to go to and it's free,
and you can go over there
and you can get a brief description
of the different personality types,
of what the Enneagram is in general.
There's a lot of information for free.
You can also take the test,
which I do think you have
to pay for on the
Enneagram Institute anyway.
- But the thing that we really want
to talk about is just kind
of explore our experience
and being exposed to the Enneagram
and starting to understand
what our numbers are
and how that has impacted how we,
how we think about ourselves,
how we think about each other,
and the people and other
people that we interact with,
like our wives.
We're thinking we're going
to make this a two-parter
because today we're
going to talk about both
of our numbers and our
experience with that.
- Right.
- And the insights we've gained
into what makes ourselves tick.
- And then probably next time
we'll spend more time talking about
how different numbers
relate to each other.
How the fact that I'm a
three and Link's a one,
like what that means in our relationship.
The way our marriages
function with the insights
that we've been given by
learning about the Enneagram.
But let's just start just really quickly,
just saying a couple of
things about what it is.
Okay, so you hear the word Enneagram,
it sounds a little bit like pentagram.
It kind of looks like a pentagram.
- Well it sounds like kilogram too.
- It is a nine-pointed diagram
that essentially represents
the fact that there are,
or the idea, I don't even know.
I don't want to use the term fact
because this is not scientific.
This is very observational
- You talkin' about a nine pointed symbol?
This sounds creepy, man.
- The idea is that there
are nine personality types.
Now, just, this is not astrology.
If you're into astrology, good for you.
I don't believe in it.
But astrology is based on
the idea that depending on
at what time you were
born during the year,
there are certain things
that are true about your personality.
Enneagram has nothing to
do with that sort of idea
that there's some sort of cosmic
thing determined about you,
based on when you were born.
- I think it's more like the
Myers-Briggs personality test
but that kind of sells it short
in terms of the history of it and I mean,
wouldn't you say?
- Yeah, well, I'm going to,
I'm going to just read to you something
from my favorite website,
enneagraminstitute.com.
Okay, from one point of view,
the Enneagram can be seen as a set
of nine distinct personality types.
Each number on the
Enneagram denoting one type.
It is common to find a little
of yourself in all nine of the types,
although one of them should stand out
as being closest to yourself.
This is your basic personality type.
Everybody emerges from childhood with one
of the nine types
dominating their personality
with inborn temperament
and other prenatal factors
being the main determinants of our type.
In other words,
this is mostly to do with discovering
who you are just genetically.
This isn't necessary,
I mean, you can argue
about how much is nature
and how much is nurture.
But this is just,
based on observation,
it seems like there are
nine sort of dominant types
of personalities that people can exhibit.
For me, and I think that I'm
speaking for Link as well.
I mean the main, like,
okay, so what's the point?
Why, what do you do?
Why, why are you into this
and why has this been
impactful or impactful?
I mean.
- You just said the same word twice.
- For me, but I emphasized
a different syllable.
The main benefit is the realization
that I am not my personality.
That's actually a huge part of this for me
because we tend to get
confused and tend to think
that we are the way we act
and the way we think, right?
But my personality and your personality
is a protective shell
that we have constructed
to protect our inner self, right?
This is something that
I explored in therapy
and the way that Enneagram kind
of lined up with it was pretty awesome.
But in the more that I
understand my personality,
the the more that I
understand what the shell is
and how the shell was constructed,
the more transparent it becomes
and the more I can look through it
and see my true inner self.
That's good for me personally
but it's also good for my relationships
because I'm able to
experience my true self,
express my true self,
but also let you as someone in my,
a relationship with me,
experience my true self.
- My experience is that it's a
nice companion knowledge base
to therapy.
Now, I don't actually talk
about the Enneagram in therapy.
Sometimes I might refer to it,
but I access some of the things
that I'm learning in those
conversations in therapy.
And so it, it can definitely
be very insightful
or I'll also say heavy, you know?
It can really help you
get access into, you know,
what's going on inside
and then help you understand
why you're doing the things
that you do and respond
to certain situations.
That's a very rewarding
process but it can also be,
you know, it's work.
It sometimes, you know, you can be,
it can be painful, you
know, to get into it.
But I'll say also,
as I was exposed to it through our group
of friends that were into it years ago,
it was also fun because it just,
I felt like all of a
sudden some things kind
of clicked into place and I
understood things and I could,
you know, all of, all of
the quirks that I have,
and I got plenty.
I didn't feel as alone or as weird.
I still love to celebrate my weirdness
and my unique-esy but there was a bit
of validation that like,
oh, I'm not alone.
I can, as much as I want to,
I can apply the labels associated with one
and feel not so,
not, not so alone.
It's kind of, I mean,
if you're into it it's
fun and you, you know.
- If you're not into it
and you have friends who are into it,
it can be a little pretentious
and annoying also as well,
but I'm into it so I'm
probably just pretentious
and annoying, but.
- It provided a common
language for our friend group
to understand each other much more quickly
on a deeper level.
To this day, we still
refer to those things.
But I mean,
there was a big wave when we
were all reading the books
and talking about it that now it just kind
of comes up occasionally.
So, you know, I'll say it can be,
it can be painful,
it can be heavy,
but it can also be fun
and I think we're going
to talk about both those things today.
- When you learn more about
your personality and you,
and you kind of learn
through this, this, you know,
the filter of the Enneagram,
it's interesting because you're kind
of learning what your strengths
and weaknesses are at the same
time because the old adage,
your greatest strength is
usually your greatest weakness.
What makes you a one,
what makes me a three,
what makes you whatever you are,
there are some strengths and weaknesses
that come along with
that and usually again,
the thing that makes you
an asset in a relationship
or an asset on a team also
in when it's not healthy,
it can make you a liability.
I think that that's the biggest thing
that we've been able to
learn because as you,
as you kind of understand like,
when I'm like, okay, that's why I'm,
oh, I do this thing?
Now that I can actually read about it
and I can see like you were saying that,
oh, there's a whole lot of other people
who have this same struggle
or have this same tendency.
It suddenly kind of
neuters it a little bit.
You know what I'm saying?
It takes the power out of it.
And I don't feel as controlled
and I actually feel like
there's a little bit of hope
for dealing with this particular
thing that is a problem.
- Right, when you separate
yourself as a personality.
- Yeah.
- Then in that you've constructed,
then you can start to change your habits
and your actions and your,
you can dismantle your
unhealthy defense mechanisms,
and you know, I'm not great at it.
I've kind of gone away from the Enneagram.
I haven't been reading a
lot about it in a few years,
but it was nice to kind
of get a refresher on it.
Let's go quickly through all of the types.
- Okay.
- But I mean, 'cause we're just going
to talk about my type in your type today,
but I'm sure people want
to hear and you know,
there's quizzes and you can go to the,
you can go to the website,
and you can start to read
these books and type yourself.
It's going to take a little bit more work
than just the one liner that
I'm going to read right now.
But I'll just go in numeric order.
Not because that puts me first,
just because, I mean, I am a one.
Type one is called the reformer.
Some people might call
it the perfectionist.
One book that we'll refer to
calls the one the machine,
which I kinda like that.
The rational, idealistic type.
Principled, purposeful, self-controlled,
and perfectionistic.
Type two, you got the helper.
That's the caring, interpersonal type.
Demonstrative, generous,
people-pleasing, and possessive.
Jessie is a type two.
- This is my wife, which we
can talk about next week.
- Type three, you've got the achiever.
That is you, Rhett.
- This is me.
- Do you like any of the other
names besides the achiever?
- Well, the same book, "Millenneagram",
which we will recommend later,
calls this the winner.
I like that.
(laughing)
- The success oriented, pragmatic type.
Adaptive, excelling,
driven, and image conscious.
- Can you tell?
- Type four.
You've got the individualist.
The sensitive, withdrawn type.
Expressive, dramatic,
self-absorbed, and temperamental.
Type five, the investigator.
The intense cerebral type.
Perceptive, innovative,
secretive, and isolated.
Type six, the loyalist.
This is my wonderful wife Christy.
The committed, security oriented type.
Engaging, responsible,
anxious, and suspicious.
Type seven, the enthusiast.
The busy, fun loving type.
Spontaneous, versatile,
distractable, and scattered.
Type eight, the challenger.
The powerful dominating type.
Self-confident, decisive,
willful, and confrontational.
Type nine, wrapping things up.
You've got the peacemaker.
The easygoing, self-effacing type.
Receptive, reassuring,
agreeable, and complacent.
- Now there's a couple of ways
to figure out what you are
and the one way is the test.
What I will say about the test is like
the section called the RHETI.
R-H-E-T-I.
It's an acronym for something
from the Enneagram Institute
has been evaluated to
be like 72% accurate.
So in other words.
- I don't think I ever took it.
- So I took that one and
there's some other free ones
that you can take online,
and you're, you might not always score.
I usually like 90% of the time,
three will be the thing that hits,
that pings the highest, right?
But another way to sort of figure out
what you are in addition to
the test is to read in depth
about each one and see
which one resonates the most
with you and I would go as far.
I think the way that my
wife put it is the one
where it feels like
they're reading your mail.
You know what I'm saying?
- You might start to get
a little embarrassed.
- You're going to have a little bit
of shame and embarrassment,
some self-consciousness that is associated
with the negative qualities of each type.
It's really those negative qualities
that you you begin to feel that,
oh, that's me.
Oh, you got me.
Yeah, you called me out.
When I read about three,
it's clear as day that that's what I,
and I think you feel very strongly
in the same way about the one.
Now some people might not,
it might be like, I, and again,
this isn't science, it's not science.
This is an observational thing
that just kind of helps
you think about yourself.
So don't feel too
discouraged if you're like,
I can't really figure
this out in an afternoon.
Maybe it's obvious for you,
maybe it's not,
but just be patient with it
if this is something
that you want to pursue.
- So let's dig into our numbers,
but first let's promote some merch.
I got this mug sitting here.
You want to travel,
you want to stay hydrated,
then you need the mythical mug.
That thing, this thing is sharp.
Well, no, it's not sharp.
It's very safe.
You just, I mean, if you're a type six,
you're like I'm not going
to get a sharp travel mug.
No, it's like it pops open in a way that,
it's perfectly designed
so that you can drink it
and then seal it up
without having to touch any
of the stuff that you don't
want to touch with your mouth.
Because I'm a one I endorse this mug
and also endorse the wacky design
of the "Good Mythical
Morning" mug as well.
- [Rhett] Wacky.
mythical.com.
Get yourself some mug action.
- Okay, I mean, since
one comes before three,
just go ahead and uh.
- All right, I'll kick it off
but we'll bounce back and forth.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I, it definitely was obvious
that I was a one in my mind very quickly.
I mean, even without
knowing about the Enneagram,
my perfectionistic tendencies, you know,
maybe it's because I'm a one
or that I identified with it immediately,
or maybe it's just like the concept
of being a perfectionist is something
that people talk about
more often than some
of these other types.
Maybe.
I don't know, I can't
tell because I'm kind
of on the inside of it.
But people tend to think
they can spot a perfectionist
because, you know, it's
a familiar term, right?
So I kind of always consider
myself a perfectionist.
Very meticulous.
So as I started to read about it,
I was like, oh yeah,
I didn't play with my toys.
I posed my toys in the
way that I wanted them
and I never touched them again.
- Right.
- You know?
I look over my family's shoulder
when they're loading the dishwasher
and I just can't help but
reload it once they're done.
Basically with any type of procedure,
I always think I know
the best way to do it
and I just can't help myself
to get my hands in there
and to rearrange it.
Gotta make things right.
- Right.
- I mean, that's a big part of it.
It goes a lot deeper than that but I mean,
speaking of going deeper,
I guess we can talk about the
childhood message of it all?
- Sure, yeah.
- Is there, so in "The
Complete Enneagram,"
it's more of the reference
book that we both read.
- Well, I think that's.
- "27 Paths to Greater Self-Knowledge."
That's the one that I read.
I didn't read the other one.
- Well, the unconscious childhood message
that the one that I just told you about,
I know is in "The Wisdom
of the Enneagram,"
'Cause that's what I was.
It could also be in "The
Complete Enneagram."
- Yeah, it says, "Chaos
or uncertainty or anxiety
in the family motivates the one child
to take on the task of providing order
and structure for himself.
The coping strategy of adhering strongly
to sound rules, and routines,
and standards of behavior provides a one
with inner cohesion and security
as well as protection from criticism."
So, you know, it's not that my mom,
my mom didn't have a
lot of rules actually.
I, things were, things were pretty loose
but I definitely had
this sense that I needed
to be a good child and that I needed
to follow the rules even,
and I would make them up for myself.
So I can definitely see, I mean,
some people will assert
that you're kind of born
with a number and that it
just kind of manifests itself
through the message that
you received as a child,
and it's like the first litmus test
of kind of what your number is.
Other people may say different things.
But for me, I think there
was this perceived insecurity
and that some of it was,
it was up to me to make
sure that we were good.
You know, it was like,
it was me and my mom.
You know, I remember
things like it just being,
okay, my mom's getting a divorce
and now it's just me and my
mom in like late grade school,
and just kind of internalizing the fact
that I need to do my
part to walk the line.
I don't, you know, I don't
want to cause any trouble.
I don't want to be the one to
create any sort of split here.
I don't, nothing was to
the point where like,
I mean I'm certainly continuing
to explore those things
from my childhood in
therapy and in my own work.
But I wouldn't say that it
was traumatic to the point.
I mean, I just think that
that's how I responded to it.
- Right.
- With, I can order my zone.
I can stay in, my room can be my place.
And if there's, if anybody
has expectations of me,
I need to do everything
I can to follow those.
So it does resonate in that way.
I think the the childhood
message is it's not okay
to make mistakes.
- Right.
- And again, I think that
was not anything that was,
I didn't have a drill
sergeant of family members
that were saying, you know, and I didn't,
I'd never experienced a lot of punishment.
It was all something that I put on myself
and that I definitely believed
as a defense mechanism
of things going wrong.
If anything goes wrong,
it can't be because I
didn't do something right
if I knew it, if I'm culpable.
- And just to give people
an idea of how personal,
how much you take it upon yourself,
it's not just the the feeling
that you can't make mistakes.
I mean, like the basic
fear of a one according
to the Enneagram Institute is
of being evil or defective.
You know what I'm saying?
So it's not about, like,
if I make a mistake,
it's going to screw things up.
It's about you.
- The core of my being is.
- If I do something wrong, I'm bad.
- I am a, yeah, it's not
just I did something wrong.
I am wrong.
And, you know, in the,
in the evangelical environment
that we grew up in,
you know that is a tenant of the faith,
is that you're born into sin.
So you're born guilty and
in need of punishment.
You deserve punishment.
You know, just by virtue
of being born and existing.
I never questioned that.
I accepted that.
Maybe it resonated with me
and I internalized that.
So that was a defining belief
and a defining part of
my experiences as well.
- Well, it's all, you know,
the different environments
that you find yourself in will,
might exacerbate it, right?
I think interestingly,
I mean one of the things
we didn't say at the top,
is there is definitely a spiritual aspect
to the roots of the Enneagram.
So it actually, the Enneagram is talked
about quite a bit in
Christian circles, right?
Both evangelical circles but
also sort of post-Christian
or liberal Christian,
progressive Christian circles.
You don't have to have any sort
of spiritual identity or you know,
that doesn't have to be a part
of your background in order
to appreciate light Link's talking about
the practical side of things.
But when you're in that
environment where you're being told
that you're bad and that
is your ultimate problem,
I think that probably
speaks to a lot of the ways
that we processed our
whole spiritual experience
so differently.
You know what I'm saying?
Which we'll get into how a three
navigates the spiritual space
when we talk about me in a second.
- Yeah, for me it was okay,
my, everything that I learned
in church growing up was okay,
a set of rules and a set of beliefs,
and an entire worldview
that's completely organized
that I was like, okay.
It gave me a sense of
comfort that existed.
All I had to do was live
up to it and you know.
- That's tough.
- Follow through with the action.
Oh yeah.
And it, and that's not, you know,
that's not ultimately the point of it
but that was certainly what I fixated on.
- Right.
- You know?
It wasn't a connection and
a relationship with God.
If you replay my spiritual
deconstruction episodes
through this lens of being a one,
it definitely makes sense and
it's helped me process it.
Another part of it is, like I said,
protection from criticism.
Like trying to do everything you can
so that someone else can't
point out your fault.
You know, I think about
when I was dating Christy
and I was just,
I was reading all these books.
I wanted to do it right.
You know, my dad, I
never lived with my dad.
You know, he left when I was two
and then my mom got remarried,
and then there was a divorce.
I don't think I ever blamed myself
for either one of those things,
but how I internalized it
is a different question.
I could definitely see
when I was dating Christy,
I was like, I don't, I wanna
make sure I do it right.
I want to read all the books
so that no stone is
left unturned with what,
with this decision I'm going to make.
Should I ask her to marry me?
- And I remember,
I remember this summer where you're trying
to figure this out
and you were like asking
all these questions,
and you were like
weighing all these things.
You were meeting with other people.
- There was like pro con
lists that I would make.
And it was as if someone was
looking over my shoulder,
analyzing my choice so that,
so that if they said
why are you doing this?
I would have all the reasons.
- Yeah, and not having any,
I mean, we, weren't very in touch
with who we were at all in college.
But, you know, I just interpreted it as
Link's being weird about this decision,
which is as simple as that.
'Cause I specifically
remember just telling you,
I was just like, do you want to marry her?
- Right.
- If answer is yes then
just ask her to marry you.
It was, for me, it was,
I tried to simplify it to that level
and then you were like,
no, no, no, no, no.
It's not that,
how could you just make
this decision based
on what you want?
- My mom always tells the story of when I,
we went out to dinner
and I was like, "Mom."
I looked at her eye and I was like,
"Mom, I think I love her."
And she was like, "Ya think?"
It's, of course you do.
You know, it's like, finally
you're figuring this out
and poor Christy,
it's like she had to wait for me
to like justify the fact
that I loved her to some,
and it wasn't to God,
it was to like any
outside criticism so that,
you know, again, I just didn't
want to make any mistakes.
And as a one you don't, you don't want to,
you know, having to defend, having to say,
yeah, I, you know, I didn't do this right.
I didn't look look at all the information.
I didn't do everything I could have.
It was, you know, it was,
I was kind of trapped and I robbed myself
of a lot of the experience
of experiencing falling
in love with Christy
and being in love,
and I would apologetically
explain love as something
that wasn't a concrete reason.
- You were trying to
break it down to something
that was even more
pragmatic than it can be.
- I mean, for what's the
childhood message for the three?
- Or where, start wherever you want to.
I don't have the perfect
episode in my mind
that I want you to adhere to.
- You're really resisting.
You're really resisting.
- Oh yeah.
- So here's one way that
I knew I was a three.
The day that Jessie told
me about the Enneagram
and she said there are
nine personality numbers.
I was like, which one's the best one?
(laughing)
I was joking.
But honestly,
that's how a three approaches
every single situation,
is how can I be the best
in this environment?
In this, with this challenge, right?
So again, little description
of the threes again.
The achiever, the performer, the winner.
Threes are self-assured, attractive.
Now the reason that it
says attractive is not
because you're naturally good looking.
It's that you're image conscious
so no matter how ugly you actually are,
even if you don't have a chin, right?
You can grow a beard over
that chin and be like,
that guy is not bad lookin'.
Don't shave.
You see what I'm saying?
That's what a three can do.
Charming, ambitious, competent, energetic.
They can also be status conscious
and highly driven for advancement.
They're diplomatic and poised
but can also be overly concerned
with their image and what
others think of them.
They typically have problems
with workaholism and competitiveness.
Who's that?
What?
At their best, self-accepting, authentic,
everything they seem to be,
role models who inspire others.
So the childhood message,
and this is this is interesting, right?
So on the surface,
it's something that I think
many of you can relate to,
and that is most parents,
and I'm one of them,
make the mistake of sort of
giving praise, and rewards,
and love to your children
when they do things well.
They make good grades,
they perform well in sports,
and some kids,
kids who are threes,
internalize that message
to this hyper-drive level
where they actually begin to
attach their own self-worth
to having pleased their parents.
So this doesn't mean that my
parents did something wrong
in telling me that it was
good to make good grades
or that being good at basketball
was something they were into.
It's that the three takes
that and builds an identity
that is based on what someone else wants.
So they call the three
the chameleon in a lot of,
because what they can do is
you put us into a situation.
Put us on a basketball team.
We're going to figure out
how to be the best player
on the basketball team.
Put us into a classroom.
We're going to figure out how
to be the smartest person in the classroom
and if we can't be the smartest,
we're going to be the best
person who is giving a speech.
We're going to find
something that we can do
and if we can't do it,
if we start thinking why I
actually can't cut it here,
we bail and we go to all the
other things that we can do
and we learn how to
navigate and be good at it.
I see this pattern repeated
so many times in my life.
Academically, with
sports, with our career.
You know,
they're the ultimate fake
it 'til you make it, right?
Threes will go into a situation knowing
that they do not know how to execute
or be good at something.
But with this belief,
I'll figure it out.
I'll get into the situation.
I will adapt.
I will learn and I will come out on top.
There's just this pathological belief
that that's how you can
approach everything.
Now.
- Bullshit artist.
- Well, we can be very
deceptive and we can be,
a lot of politicians.
A lot of politicians are threes.
- Bill Clinton.
I got a list here, yeah.
- But.
- Michael Jordan
- Now.
- Is he a politician?
- I mean, a lot of people
who have succeeded in like,
Tiger Woods is a three.
A lot of people who have succeeded sort
of exceptionally in a particular field
to a maniacal level happen to be threes.
- Oprah.
- But Oprah!
But what are we running from?
Why?
Why are we like this?
Why am I like this?
So, you know,
I think this is the thing
that has been so impactful
and the beginning of
transformative as it comes
to like my therapy and
exploring these ideas,
is that actually our basic
fear is of being worthless.
The unconscious childhood message
that we received was,
not that we received but
that we latched on to.
Again, I want to make sure
that this isn't coming across as like.
- Blaming your parents?
- Your parents did something.
This is what we latched onto
because of our disposition.
The message that I received
and believed was it's not okay
to have your own feelings and identity.
Now there's a lot of reasons
why that might be the case.
But what you end up doing is
to not have your own identity.
What that means is that threes
have a really difficult time
figuring out what they want
because what they're really
good at is figuring out
what you want, what the
environment that they want.
Think about campus ministry, right?
I have had a tendency
throughout my entire life,
when you put me into an environment,
I find a way to navigate
to the top of it, right?
So what did I do in campus ministry?
We went to one campus crusade event
and I saw that there was
a guy out there talking.
Every week he was introducing people.
He was making jokes.
He was in videos.
And it just clicked and a
wasn't a conscious process.
It was like I'm going to be that person.
Because I can't navigate
a space in any other way.
So the next year I was that person, right?
And so, but what are we,
what are we running from?
We believe that the moment that
we stop asserting ourselves
and the moment that we
stop being this thing
that other people have found value in,
that we don't have any value.
That we are a worthless.
So it's actually this tricky thing
where it's not this thing.
We don't actually think that we're great.
We actually think that we're not great.
We think that we are ultimately worthless
unless we can do something for you,
unless we can perform in a way
that you're like good job, great job.
And if we don't get that,
we begin to disappear.
I mean the worst fear
that I have is like being incapacitated.
Like literally like, oh,
what if I'm in an accident
and I can't do what I do anymore?
Like, that is what a three is scared of.
Because the moment that people have to,
and this is what,
we also tend to be incredibly independent.
I don't want you doing something for me.
Don't help with something
because that means that I'm,
that I can't do it and
I might be worthless.
So receiving things from people,
receiving help from people.
We're not good at that
because we want to do it.
Again, not because we think,
it comes across as arrogance.
I'm very aware of that.
It comes across like, oh, you're
arrogant, you're prideful.
You think you're shit.
That's sort of the external
impression that we can give.
The soft underbelly of that is we actually
are afraid that we're not those things.
We're afraid that we're worthless.
We're afraid that if we
cannot perform for you
then we will fade away into non-existence.
- That's, yeah, and
that's, that's kind of sad.
But it's nice to get in touch with that
so you can start to say,
okay, how am I going to grow?
How going to integrate these insights?
'Cause for me, it's yeah.
It's, if I'm not, you know,
I guess I'm afraid of
there not being an answer
or there not being a, like a perfect way.
You know, it's like, if
there's not an answer,
well, how am I, what am I supposed to do?
- But again, one step below that,
if my ultimate fear is of being worthless,
your ultimate fear is of being bad.
- Yeah, of being, yeah.
- Corrupted.
- Of being fundamentally flawed as opposed
to being fundamentally good.
Nailing it, nailing it.
- And you know what?
We'll get into this in a second.
There's subtypes, right?
So there's wings and there's subtypes.
We'll talk about that.
But the specific subtypes
that we are actually makes us similar
in some really interesting ways.
We'll talk about that.
But the thing about
like this desire to be,
to not make a mistake, to
be good that the one has,
and then this desire to accomplish.
I'm not saying that,
there have been some
situations and I can't,
I wish I could think of one where we have
to make a decision about something
and it's a much easier decision for me
because I'm just like,
do we want to do this or
would this be a good look?
And then you'll kind of
get caught up on yeah,
but is this the right thing to do?
- Yeah.
- You know, and I actually think
it's a really good balance,
because it, the sort of the one-two punch
of that decision-making process
is it can be very powerful.
But there are a few times
where I'm just like,
hm, Link is really link
is really spending a lot
of time thinking about the merit of that,
like the moral merit of this
and I'm spending a lot of
time thinking about like,
what it will do for us.
I'm not talking about like,
oh, I'm going to bend the rules.
Now threes we'll do that.
Threes will bend the rules.
Threes will break the law.
Threes will lie in order
to take advantage of you.
A healthy three doesn't do that.
I consider myself a three
that is moving towards health
and is at times healthy so
that being deceptive is not,
I'm not a liar.
That's not a, that's not a problem.
I'm not gonna lie to you to
try to get something past you.
I guess there may have
been times in my life
that I would have done
that but thankfully,
that hasn't been one of the things
that I've had to deal with.
- One of the things,
I guess to bounce back to the one.
Like one of the hallmarks
of oneness is an incessant inner critic.
Now a lot of people,
and I guess of many different numbers,
can describe having an inner critic.
An inner voice that is analyzing
and assessing your
performance, your actions.
Whatever the case may be.
Measuring you against the standard.
But the inner critic of a
one is a constant thing.
Again, to quote the textbook,
"Ones internalize a parental
voice that functions therefore
as an internal critic or coach.
This coping strategy of
proactively criticizing oneself
and trying to do things correctly prior
to coming under parental scrutiny
can avoid outside
criticism and punishment."
It can be crushing
because it's so constant.
Like I remember when I
had my lawn mowing job
when I was like 14, 15, and on into 17.
You know, around my Nana and Papa's house.
Like they got me this gig.
First of all, Nana was
the one who was like,
I remember she would always
say don't half ass it.
If you're going to do
anything, go all the way.
Do it right.
I mean, she was the closest
to like the concrete voice
of find the right way to do it and do it.
- Right.
- Or don't do it at all.
Chew your food 30 times.
Chew your food a lot.
It was probably.
She might've never said 30 times.
She might've just thrown that out there
as like a ballpark figure,
which is really high.
But to me, that was like, okay,
now I know I'm going to
count 30 times every time.
And when I'm done with this podcast,
I'm going to go to the dentist
and get fitted for a mouth
guard so that you know,
I don't chew my mouth to
shreds while I'm sleeping.
- You're chewing it at night.
You're practicing chewing
while you're sleeping.
- Yeah, as a 43-year-old.
But I remember I would cut grass
and I usually didn't
have my cassette Walkman
because I didn't want to get it dusty.
I would, it's definitely not a CD player
because it would skip too much.
So I would just be there
alone with my thoughts
and my thoughts were my inner
critic in the form of a,
it was like a sports commentator
or like a couple of them
talking to each other.
It was constant chatter about how well
I was mowing the grass.
So if you listened in on
my thoughts at any point
for the hours and hours that
I was mowing all those lawns?
I wasn't daydreaming
at least half the time.
It wasn't daydreaming, or like,
you know, just zoning out.
It was listening to these commentators
that I was manufacturing
talking about oh yeah,
that corner, you know,
he kinda missed a little grass.
He's going to have to go back
for that one on the second round.
And then oh, the grass is
a little long this day.
What's his strategy going to be?
And then ultimately,
how long did it take him to
cut Miss Bathoone's grass
and get paid while listening
to her talk about her ceramics?
Be nice but not stay too long
that he's going to get home before dark.
You know, it was, and
I just thought it was,
it was motivating for me.
Like I listened to these voices
and I got really good at mowing grass.
But it wasn't this, it wasn't an outlet.
It was just, it was a
barrage of assessment.
It was constantly there.
- It's striking how
similar the inner thoughts,
inner dialogue of a three is
to a one to hear you say that.
- So for me, it's here's
a standard of perfection.
Are you, are you a cheat?
Are you a, I'll say, I'll
use the word achieve.
Are you achieving it or not?
But I guess your inner critic
is saying achieve something different.
- No, no.
So, well, it's so similar and that's why,
first of all, people, and I,
there are people that I'm close to
that are not into the Enneagram
and I don't know if
there are three or a one,
which you may be like, what?
It seems so different.
Okay, here's why it's not different.
Because the net effect of
you having this inner critic
that won't show up that's
in the form of these two,
you know, announcers,
is that you're constantly
focusing on your performance.
You may be doing it because you don't want
to make a mistake.
Now, shift the analogy a little bit
into say I'm mowing the grass.
Well, what am I thinking about?
I'm not thinking about
the two commentators.
I'm thinking about the
crowd that is watching.
I'm thinking about the audience.
So I don't have an internal critic.
I have an inner audience
that I am performing for constantly.
I told my therapist about
this and a lot of times,
frankly, it's my parents and my brother.
It's my family, it's my immediate family.
Like, I'll be doing something.
As a 43-year-old man,
I'll be doing something
stupid like cleaning a window,
or painting something,
or changing a tire on my kid's bicycle,
and I picture them watching me
and saying he's doing a pretty good job
with that bicycle tire.
- [Link] Mm hm.
- I mean, now of course
it manifests itself
in things like, oh, well,
he's on "The Tonight Show."
Or he just won an award for that show
that he makes on the internet.
But it is these inner audience
that I'm performing for.
When you talk about that inset,
it's all, they're always there.
The cloud of witnesses,
they're always there.
They're always watching and I
hope they're always impressed.
Right?
If I'm by myself, if I'm,
I mean one of the things I struggle
with when I meditate is the moment
that I begin to focus
on my breath in a way
that's actually not
encumbered by my thoughts,
which is very difficult for me to do.
The moment that I focus on my breath,
the audience is like, he's doing it.
He's focusing on his breath.
It's like, and it goes right
back back to having to perform,
and it's the most difficult thing
to shed and to let go of.
But again,
if you're just watching
somebody on the outside,
you just see two guys doing a
really good job cutting grass.
One guy, Link, the one,
is competing against this inner standard
that he's established for himself.
The other guy who's
doing a really good job
as well is thinking about
the guy across the street
with the mower and how
he's better than him.
How he's doing a better job
than all the other people
who might be mowing and he's obsessed
with not just beating his own standard
but beating the standard.
What's the standard for
mowing in Lillington?
Whatever that is, I'm going to the top.
- Yeah.
- And again, a lot of
these inner struggles,
like when you think,
when you talk about any,
you might feel exhausted when you hear
about the inner dialogue
of a one and a three.
I think that's probably the case
for most any the way
that I talk to Jessie.
I mean, the inner dialogue
of a two, it's like,
oh, that is, I feel so sorry for you.
That is exhausting
because this is the thing
that you're constantly running from.
I can't take a vacation, right?
I'm a workaholic, right?
So I go on vacation.
Here's this perfect example.
A couple years ago we were
getting ready for our tour,
the Rhett & Link Sing Song tour,
or whatever we called.
- That was not what we called it.
- I had told everybody that I was going
to learn how to play the
piano for this tour, right?
So of course now that I did that,
I had to do it.
I'm sitting on vacation
in Cabo San Lucas next
to a pool relaxing.
Now my wife is doing, she can relax.
She can do it.
Day one of vacation, she's poolside.
She's got a book that's like fiction.
Like a fiction book, you know?
And she's just enjoying herself.
One of the reasons I have
trouble reading fiction
is I feel like I'm not fixing anything.
I'm not learning anything.
It's just a story that's
going to go in one ear
and out the other.
But I remember sitting
poolside and I was like,
boy, you know what this is
the perfect opportunity for?
This is a perfect
opportunity to write a song
because we gotta,
I gotta write a song for this.
I gotta play the piano.
I gotta write a song.
And I wrote that's why I travel
and that's why it's about
being at a Mexican resort
because I was at a Mexican
resort at the time.
And it was like, and again.
- You have to be doing something.
- If I don't do that.
- You have to be achieving something.
- If I choose to be like, you know what?
Today I'm not writing a song.
I'm not thinking about,
I'm not contemplating a project.
I'm not trying to be a better me.
I'm just being.
Again, that's the ultimate
thing for a three is,
stop doing and start being.
Learn how to be, not do.
Very difficult for me to do
because the moment that
I don't do anything,
I get this, it feels like
the world is caving in.
Even this past weekend,
I spent like an afternoon.
I watched a movie and then I
kinda just napped on Saturday.
- Yeah.
- There was like a four hour
window where it was like,
it was a movie and then a nap.
At the end of that I was like,
I feel horrible.
What could I have,
what else could I have
done in that four hours?
I could have like,
I could have figured
something out creatively.
- Well, this is what I did this weekend.
Were you done with your thought, though?
- Yeah.
Well, I want to come back
to the wings in a second
'cause the wing,
but I want to hear what you gotta say.
- Yeah, for me this
weekend, it was, you know,
I was vacuuming the vents.
- Yeah, the vents, they get dirty.
- Because you look up
there and you can start
to see that boy, they're dirty,
and I would take them down.
I realized there was
so much more I could do
to vacuum inside of the vent.
- Yeah, you can go all
the way up in there.
- That type of stuff.
When I was done with all that,
I realized that the vacuum
cleaner was really dirty.
So I disassembled the vacuum
cleaner and cleaned all of it.
The thing about ones is we can relax
if we can manage to put things
in just the right order.
We can have this sense of wellbeing
when things are are put in their place.
Like oh, I've cleaned and the thing
that I cleaned with is now totally clean,
so now I can relax.
But if I just cleaned the vents
and I made my vacuum cleaner dirty,
well I've created a problem
and that's not made right yet,
so I couldn't chill out.
Now this is a trap, of course.
But I do know that sometimes
when I'm cleaning or organizing,
those things make me feel better
because they give me
that sense of control,
which is associated with
achieving perfection
in my own mind.
Control is really for me
like, nailing perfection.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it's not about whether it's out
of my control or in my control.
It's like, it's whether the,
I can achieve a result
with control and there's,
you know, there's plenty
of things that I will not,
I get very sensitive to signing up
for things if I don't know what,
if I don't know how to get to
the end goal of perfection.
Like if it's, if it's open-ended
or if I feel like it's a big commitment
and I'm not going to be able to,
if I get 80% or 70%,
even if it's a friendship.
Remember that story I told
about the guy who was just like,
he was just a friend who wanted
to continue to be a friend,
ad I broke up with him
because I didn't feel like
I could be a good enough friend to him?
So I like preemptively
just broke up with the guy.
I mean, that's what was behind it.
- Well, and this is another
area where the threes
and the ones are so alike.
In fact, the three one combo
which we'll talk more about next week,
there's actually a nickname
for the three one combo.
- Oh don't tell, don't tell yet.
I don't know.
- I don't know what it is.
- Okay.
- But basically it's the combo of numbers
that will accomplish the most
if you put them together.
- Ooh.
- Because they're both
ultimately super committed
to results.
And again, like, okay,
so the one, like, what you're saying is,
you're hesitant to enter into a situation
if you don't feel like you're
going to be able to do it
and you're going to be able to control it.
A three will gladly
very, they will sign up.
We will get right in.
We have no idea.
We haven't been educated in this area.
We've never done it before.
It doesn't matter.
We're jumping in.
The moment that we begin to believe
that we will not achieve,
that's when we bail.
Most threes.
- And for me, I cannot bail.
So it's like, if I sign up for it,
I feel like I have to do it.
So it's like.
- So I think that again, this,
the three one combo is
that I will convince you
to jump into something
and then I've got this
pathological confidence
that we will be able to
figure it out and do it.
And then once you set your mind to it,
now we're a team, you know?
So it ends up like, again,
we've we kind of talked,
before we understood the Enneagram,
we talked about it with
like the analogy of like,
you got one guy who gets the ball rolling
and you got the other guy
who keeps the ball rolling.
- A starter and a finisher.
- That is how it manifests
itself a lot as three to one.
Now, interestingly as this relates to,
I want to talk about
the wings a little bit.
So an aspect of the Enneagram
is that you can be a number
with a wing and the wing isn't the number
that is immediately adjacent
to each side of you.
So I could be a three with a two wing
or a three with a four wing,
and you can also be a three
without a wing, right?
But as the more I read about three,
I'm definitely not a two.
First of all, let me just say right now.
Two, which is what my wife
is, which is a helper.
And again, I think that's kind
of a demeaning name to give to the two.
There are better names
for it in other books.
It makes it seem like
I'm just here to help.
It just basically means that
they kind of give themselves
to people in ways that
are just monumental.
I'm not that.
In fact, I score the lowest on two.
Like if you look at my scores,
like two is like barely ticking.
But four, which is the individualist,
I actually scored pretty high on,
and a three with a four wing.
This isn't let me, I'm going to read.
This is from "Millenneagram."
A three with a four wing
means that I'm most concerned
with what I produce and
put out into the world.
So that's where I found my value.
It's not just necessarily like, hey,
now again, it is like hey,
we're doing this thing
where we're throwing darts at a board.
Well, I'm going to do the damnedest job
I can possibly do in this game.
That's why I'm so competitive
in GMM in a lot of ways, right?
Because you just put a challenge in front
of me and I'm just like,
well, how do you win this?
But really it manifests
itself in I am trying
to find my worth in the
things that I produce, right?
So what that ends up
doing is the net effect
of that is every single
thing that we produce,
every single thing that
we put out into the world,
my self worth is attached to it.
Now that's kind of true.
You might say that's true
for all creative people.
I believe that it is
true in a lot of ways.
But it is fundamental to my core
that I have been in this
long adulthood battle
to detach my self worth from
the success of what we do.
But that's my tendency.
My tendency, and I think
that's one of the reasons
that when I'm not healthy,
I get so defensive.
So we talked,
you know last week or a
couple weeks ago about.
- Failed projects.
- GMM 22, the multi-episode
version of GMM.
When it failed and when it
was in the midst of failing,
when it was in the midst of getting
this incredibly negative
reaction from fans,
we decided that we were
going to do a podcast
and talk about it.
Now, we made the mistake
of just being like,
we're just going to be real,
and raw, and just process this live.
I made an ass of myself
in a lot of ways, right?
I was super defensive.
I insulted people who
were disappointed in us.
I was like a cornered dog, you know?
I attacked and I lashed out.
What I have come to understand
is that I was defending my own worth.
Not saying it was healthy.
It was unhealthy because
I had so attached.
I had identified my self-worth
with the success of the show.
When people were rejecting the show,
they weren't just rejecting me.
They were telling me
that kind of worthless.
Like you took this time,
you hired all these people,
you put all this thought
and effort into this thing.
You know what?
It's shit, man.
That's what it is.
It's the shittiest thing
you guys have ever done.
So what I hear is you are shit.
You're worthless.
- Yeah.
I may have told you that too, sorry.
- So when I'm in the bad head space.
Well first of all, should
have never made that podcast,
I don't think.
Maybe we learned something from it.
But if I had to go back,
I think there was a way to process
that rejection in a healthy way
but that wasn't what I did
because I tied as a
three with a four wing,
it's about the things that I bring to you.
I'm like, here's something else.
Here's something else.
Here's a book.
Here's a concert.
Here's a song.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm constantly bringing
you things and you're,
I'm like, am I worth something now?
Is it okay?
Am I enough now?
Can I stop?
That's the process that's going on.
- And you know,
they talk about the
emotional passion associated
with each one.
What is that for a three?
- The emotional passion?
- Yeah.
For a one, it is anger.
- Oh yeah.
For a three it's deceit.
- Okay, so does that,
I don't know how that plays into this
because to me it feels like the thing
that I access is that okay,
ones most often feel resentment,
which is a kind of a low level
background tamped down anger
that things aren't as they should be.
So I try to remember,
I don't remember what
I said in that podcast
and how I was processing that.
But I think that something
that had to be going on
was just this frustration
that it didn't work
and that I, I mean,
my mind definitely goes back
to the things that we foresaw
that we needed to work
in terms of the tool.
Like, I start to blame how YouTube worked
and we talked a lot about that because,
and I fixated on that because
I felt like we had a plan
and there's things that we
needed that didn't exist.
It didn't work in a way to give
the audience the experience
that I wanted.
The perfect experience wasn't possible.
When it became impossible
and it didn't pan out
and didn't meet my standard,
I just got very resentful and frustrated
because there was there
was no way forward.
It failed because it wasn't
going to come together.
You know?
So for me, that's where the anger comes.
That's how I experience this anger,
this like seething frustration
that things aren't right.
I do think that it's like, well, I knew,
I knew what it would take.
But that part was out of our control
and when we asked for it,
we didn't get it.
Now I'm just mad because it feels like,
it feels like I'm wrong and I'm bad,
but it wasn't me.
It wasn't my fault.
- And this on a, like a smaller
level than the GMM 22 thing.
We talk about this openly.
You know, we'll be in the
middle of say a production
of some kind that's getting,
I begin to feel this is a little much.
This is taking a lot of time.
There's a whole lot going on here
and then like, we'll be,
it'll be like Wednesday
in the middle of the week
and I'll be like, Link seems angry today.
Right?
I think it's because there
are so many things going on
and or you tell me.
Maybe it's like,
I feel like I I'm losing my sense
of understanding and control.
I feel like I'm on a roller coaster
that is suddenly like one
of the wheels may have just come off.
- I always have an idea of
how things should be going
and when it is not happening,
then it just, yeah, it's very frustrating.
Very frustrating.
- But you don't.
- Because I've seen it.
I've seen it happen in my mind.
- But it's not a passive like,
there might be some types.
Like I think a nine tends to
sort of retreat a little bit.
A one doesn't retreat.
A one turns up the volume
on the aggressiveness.
- I can fix this!
It's not too late to fix this.
- We talk about that sometimes.
I'm like you're being a little aggressive.
You're being a little
aggressive right now.
Because you're like, well,
if I could turn up the volume on this
and we can just get through this.
- If I can dig claws into it deeper
and start to steer it or mold it,
then maybe it's not too late.
- Now the whole deceit,
I'm glad you asked that question.
So it might be like what do you mean?
What does that mean,
that the three's sort
of passion is deceit?
Wouldn't it be pride?
No, actually the two's passion is pride.
Talk to my wife about that.
Again, just to remind you,
we don't actually think that we're great.
We just want to seem
like we're great, right?
Again, I use, this is a funny analogy,
but I just I use the example of,
I'm not trying to make
you feel sorry for me.
I grow a beard because I do not like
the way my face looks without it, right?
I am actively deceiving you.
Except for those of you
who are able to find
that picture that's all over
the place on the internet.
- Oh, it's easy to find.
- It's the worst.
I don't actually look
that bad without a beard.
That picture that you took,
something about my hair, my expression,
I was a little bit
overweight in the chin area.
It's the worst picture on the internet.
And it's like a meme now.
- Yeah.
- Can you tell that I'm upset about it
'cause I can't control my
image like a three wants to?
But again, what I want to
do is I want to deceive you.
So I don't want to.
- So you're talking like Snapchat filters,
but across your whole life.
- Well, I, again, I want to be very clear
and I don't want to mischaracterize threes
or mischaracterized myself, because again,
I am not a liar.
I don't like get into a situation.
I don't cheat on my taxes.
I don't have an offshore account.
I'm not that kind of person.
I'm sure there are many threes who are.
But that active sort of
deception is not what it is.
It's a very, it's much more subtle
and it's much more sneaky
because I am lying to myself.
I'm trying to present myself
to myself in a way that is acceptable.
So we might be, we might be in GMM 22.
GMM 22's falling apart and I'm trying
to find a way to reposition the argument
so that I'm still okay.
Then I say same things like
you guys don't even understand
how you're supposed to
understand this thing.
You know, I don't remember
what kind of stuff I said.
But again, I don't actually believe that.
I know if my inner self
knows this is failing,
it isn't good,
but I can't deal with it not being good,
so I'm going to start lying to myself
and I'm going to start lying to you.
Not just some big, giant lie.
But I'm going to start.
- Spin.
- Spinning it a little bit.
That's why we make great politicians,
because you can ask us about,
well, why do you, did you say this in 1998
and now you're saying this now.
It's like, well let me tell you why.
You're wrong, I'm right.
It was never a change.
It was the same thing.
It was just a slightly different emphasis.
We're masters at that kind of deception.
But again, we're lying to ourselves
as much as we're lying to you.
- I mean, I can definitely
see that even for me,
I might try to change the rules in order
to like my measurement of perfection.
Look at it in a different way.
I think one of the challenges
for me is just judging.
You know I'm constantly judging myself,
but then I'm judging everything
or assessing everything to
then know what the standard is.
I'm always searching for the standard.
Matter of fact, like when
I was choosing which type
of engineering I wanted to go into,
I gravitated towards
industrial engineering.
One of the reasons was
because it was all about
taking something that it, you know,
you weren't, it wasn't
about making something.
It was about how you make it,
how you go about it,
the way you do it.
There is, it was such a focus on procedure
and systems that it
really resonated with me.
I was like, okay, just
like any math problem,
there's this, there is steps
to then get to a solution.
There is a best way to do something
and there's always a
way to improve something
to get closer and closer to perfection.
You know, I think that,
I know that perfection is an illusion,
but it's I have this drive
to get as close as I can to start,
you know, to dial the fine
tuning as much as possible.
So like very detail oriented.
It's like any little thing
to get everything in order.
So that's why I even
went into engineering.
Industrial engineering
specifically was for that reason.
- And it's, again, my threeness,
it gives a very clear explanation
as to how I navigated my
engineering situation, right?
So, okay, so I went into engineering
because originally I
wanted to be an architect.
Like growing up,
I wanted to be an architect
and I would like do house
plans and stuff like that.
Then someone told me that design school
was like really, really difficult,
and it was a lot of time.
So I was like, that doesn't sound fun.
That sounds too hard maybe.
But you know what?
Structural engineering is
like the engineering side
of design school.
So I can still kind of be
involved in architecture
and you know, my friends like Link
are going into engineering.
I've been told that I'm good at math.
Okay, I'll do that.
So then halfway through my freshman year
or maybe it was, I can't remember.
I'm taking a structural engineering class.
I'm like this is the hardest thing
I've ever taken in my life.
Like, I don't know if I
understand what's going on.
I admit I'm like,
I've been able to sort
of fake it and make A's.
- There's no real place to hide.
- But like, I think this
guy's going to give me a C!
I've never gotten a C in my life!
At that moment,
when I started to see
that I don't know if,
I didn't know if I could succeed,
I was like, well,
oh, there's also this concentration
in civil engineering called hydrology,
which is just like dealing with water.
How hard is that, right?
- Oh gosh.
- So I switched over to like
straight up civil engineering
with a concentration in hydrology,
and it was easier and I had more fun.
But again, it was the three in me.
It was the three facing an obstacle
that he thought he
couldn't actually, again,
I got myself into it.
I went into engineering.
But once I was like,
oh, you actually can't
succeed in this lane.
I shifted.
- I think another thing for me is like,
now everything we do has a post-mortem.
Well, this has always
been the case creatively.
Whenever we make anything
and I'm talking about like at
every stage of the process,
so if we shoot an episode
of "Good Mythical Morning,"
we go back to the dressing
room and we're like,
you know, getting on with our day.
I am talking, I am thinking
and talking about everything
that just happened to assess
what could've been better.
Because it's never come back and like,
well, that was good, man.
Like, I very rarely shoot
an episode being like
that was good.
It's always like, you know what?
I can always find something.
- And I hate these meetings, by the way.
- Yeah, and we institutionalize
this thing where
if you know there's always a
lesson to be learned in order
to make something incrementally better,
and the increments get smaller
and smaller and smaller,
but my tenacity to find it,
it gets more intense and more intense.
I'm like, we have to have something
'cause I know it's not perfect
because I know that's an illusion.
But we can always get closer.
- What I always tell
you in those meetings,
and again, I think that I'm
glad we do the meetings.
I'm not saying we
shouldn't do the meetings.
But a lot of times you'll
see me frame things like,
you know you may be right
that we can learn this little lesson
and we can make this improvement.
In the grand scheme of things,
do you think it will make
a substantially better product, right?
Now maybe it will but I always kind of try
to talk myself into like, yeah,
but what else could we
be doing with our time?
Like, let's find something.
- What else could we achieve?
- Let's find something else to achieve.
There's this idea that I
got from "Millenneagram,"
where it talks about threes
actually are addicted
to achieving and competing with ourselves.
Always aiming for another level of success
that is just out of reach.
It's tantalizingly out of reach.
So, you know, we talked
about all the other stuff
that we try to do and
we're like, you know.
We're trying to do something
in a traditional space.
We're trying to get a TV show on the air.
We're trying to make a movie.
We're trying to do these things.
It feels like it's this
next level of success.
Now I understand that like,
there's more kids, in fact,
Mr. Beast did a survey on Twitter
that showed that more people want
to be YouTube than actors
or more people want
to be successful on YouTube
than in the traditional space.
I get that.
I understand that.
But I ain't a kid
and I've been successful
in the YouTube space.
- Yeah, you've done it.
- I've done it.
So it's like, all right,
what else can I do, right?
I actually, I gravitate towards things
that feel like they probably
won't be able to happen.
They feel like they're out of reach
because I'm addicted to
reaching for something
that's just out of reach and
then possibly getting it.
I want to talk about.
- And it drives me crazy because I'm like,
oh, he's going to,
what's the next thing he's
going to sign me up for
that I have to perfect.
- Right.
- And, you know, I feel like
I have a limited capacity
to continue to drill into things.
- [Rhett] Right.
- Because everything that we've
added is still in my mind,
on my plate.
- Has to be perfected.
- I've, you know, I've
actually shed some things
from my plate and shed some of,
some of this desire to, you know,
to round the edges and
perfect every little thing.
But it is a tendency and at
those moments where it's like,
we're jumping into this next thing,
let's make it happen.
I'm like what is he signing me up for?
- [Rhett] Right.
- You know, even when you
go back to all the layers.
This is a conversation we
had in an early podcast,
where you're like,
it's that next thing that
you want to experience?
And you did talk about it
in terms of experience.
But I have to think there's
like an achievement.
I can now pilot an ultralight.
I can now do this.
I'm guessing?
But for me it's like, okay,
am I going to get into
this genre of music?
Because then I need to know.
I need to collect
everything in that genre or.
- It's not always like,
if you use surfing as an example.
I also tend to sign up
for things that, okay,
I'm six foot seven and
I'm in my mid-forties.
Being, I'm never going
to be a good surfer.
I'm never going to be the
kind of person that like,
I'm not trying to be.
I was never trying to
be like a real surfer,
a professional surfer, for God's sake.
But just the idea of like being someone
who doesn't look awkward and embarrassing,
if you happen to be watching them.
Lots of people were watching
me because I'm so damned big.
- That's why you don't want
to do stand up paddle board.
- Well, there's a reason,
there's multiple reasons why I don't want
to do stand up paddleboard.
Yeah, I don't like drawing attention
to myself doing something poorly,
and being on a standup paddleboard,
you're already sort of an outcast.
There's also beaches that
you can't go to, whatever.
But yeah, I struggle with it.
But in health,
I am able to be like I
can just experience this.
I can just experience the ocean.
I can just experience in these projects
that we're doing that may
never come to the light of day.
May never see the light of day.
The process, being.
Not being, I am doing, and
I'm not going to stop doing.
The answer is not to stop doing
but the answer is to be able
to be in the midst of doing, right?
But I want to talk a
little bit about feelings.
- Yeah, let's talk about
that and I do think that,
'cause what we were about to get into
would be a good thing to
talk about next episode is,
what we're doing with all
of this information in terms
of growth and integration,
as well as our interaction.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm just going to set
up one additional sort of.
- So I just controlled,
I just produced the episode a little bit.
- I'm used to it.
I just want to set up like one,
and we can talk how I'm
dealing with this next time
and also talk about like the
three and one relationship,
the two three relationship in my marriage,
the one six relationship in your marriage,
maybe even some parenting things.
This has impacted our parenting.
But this is going to surprise you
if you don't know anything
about the Enneagram.
But there are different triads, right?
There's nine total numbers,
and so there's three, three, and three.
There's a triad called the feeling triad.
This is called the heart center.
These are the people who
are most in their heart
and have the most feelings.
Three is right in the
middle of the feeling triad.
You're like, what?
That doesn't make any sense.
You don't seem like you are,
you don't feel that much.
You don't seem very sensitive.
Well, threes are not
known as feeling people.
Rather they are people of
action and achievement.
We've actually put our feelings in a box
so that we can get ahead with
whatever we want to achieve.
We believe that emotions get
in the way of our performance
so we substitute thinking and
practical action for feelings.
But let me tell you,
we have a lot of feelings and
this is why I am in therapy.
Okay?
Because I am naturally very sensitive
and feeling things deeply all the time.
But those feelings seem so impractical.
They seem, they're not pragmatic at all.
How is a feeling going
to help me do something?
So we become masters at
putting a dam up between us
and our feelings,
and let me tell you,
that dam cracks and that dam can burst,
and it can make things
happen weird in your body,
and it can give you lower back pain,
and it can give you a,
almost a detached retina,
or whatever it was that happened to me.
I know it wasn't that,
it was something else.
It can manifest itself in health problems,
which I've had a lot of them.
Skin conditions.
Because you can become
an expert at being like,
I can have this really
strong feeling and I can,
I'm an expert at transmuting
a feeling into an action.
Like it just bypasses right past me.
It's like I'm having this strong feeling.
Boom, what's the plan?
If I have a conversation with
my wife and she's dealing
with something where what
she needs is comfort,
what she needs is a listening ear.
What she needs is someone to actually get
into the trench with her.
I want to show you the way out.
I want to immediately give you a solution
and let's begin to do it right now.
Let's not sit in this discomfort.
So we're not good at comforting people.
I'm not good at going and seeing
somebody in a hospital bed.
I'm not good at knowing
what to say at a funeral.
I'm the worst and threes
might be the worst
because we stay so far away from feelings,
but inside there's this
giant water wheel turning,
with the power of all these feelings,
and it makes us need therapy!
(laughing)
If you're a three.
Everybody needs therapy,
but if you're a three
and want to be healthy,
you especially need it.
Because.
- Well, you're saying that
because you're a three.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody, everybody,
everybody needs therapy
is my opinion.
But because the threes.
- My opinion is I know I need it
and I'm going to stay
out of their business.
- No, what I'm saying is that
a three is feeling the most
in suppressing the most and
I never understood that.
Jessie would tell me all the time.
She's like, I would be like, I just,
I'm just not that sensitive.
I'm really independent.
I'm not that sensitive.
I don't care what people say to me.
I don't care.
Like you don't have to
give me birthday gifts.
I'm never an inconvenience for people.
I'm super stable and reliable.
Like I pride myself on all these things.
I don't really have that many feelings.
But I was having giant waves of feelings
that I was able to defer.
- This was a revelation to yourself.
- And in therapy, I have been able to,
I mean I'm in like my
third year of therapy.
Peel back those layers and be like,
oh no, there is a feeling and
that feeling does not need
to be transformed into action.
That feeling needs to be felt.
- We'll keep going with
that next week, I think.
And as a one, I think
I'm in the gut triad.
Honestly, I don't know what that means.
I also find it interesting
that like, in this,
in this episode, as we wrap up,
it felt like you had,
you took the opportunity to
like help people understand
some misconceptions about you.
You know, it's like.
- 'Cause I'm an image management.
- And I think I don't,
I don't know what my drive is.
I dunno, I'll think about that.
But for next week I think, yeah.
'Cause there's still lots of,
there's lots of good
stuff in terms of like,
okay, where do we go from here that like,
it'll be fun to process in the next one.
So I say let's leave it at that,
but you need to give a rec.
- Yeah, so there's a bunch of
good books that we have read.
Really, I would be lying
to you if I told you
that I had read it all
through all of these.
My wife has.
- That's the good thing,
is that you only have
to read like the parts
about your number at first.
So it's like a big book.
You can have a sense of
achievement or that you didn't,
you didn't quit.
- So I'll say that if you want to go,
if you want to go a little bit deeper,
"The Complete Enneagram"
or "The Wisdom of the
Enneagram" are great.
But if you are like most people these days
and you don't want to go deeper
because it takes a lot of time
and you want to read something
that is a little bit more approachable,
a little bit more irreverent,
I think that "Millenneagram."
- I'd say it's a lot more reverent.
You gotta like F bombs.
But it's a really fun book.
- "Millenneagram" by Hannah Paasch.
This is definitely, I mean,
first of all, it's great.
A lot of the stuff that
I talked about today,
it came directly from the
insights in this book.
But it doesn't go as deep
into like the background
of how this whole thing came about
and it doesn't feel as technical,
and I'm saying that for most
people that's a good thing.
It's approachable.
It's digestible.
"Millenneagram."
It's pretty too, look at that.
It's got a bunch of colors on the front.
- Yeah, I like it.
Lots of fun.
All right, we'll keep
this going next week,
but hey, go ahead.
#EarBiscuits.
Let us know about your experience.
If you're a one or a three,
what's resonating or just as
you've been exposed to this,
what's your experience with the Enneagram?
- And maybe over the next week,
now that you've heard this episode,
you can actually begin to
explore this for yourself.
Maybe when you listen
to next week's episode,
you already know or begin
to be knowing what you are.
- [Link] To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.